In your opinion, do you think my MRI findings show that I should do something more drastic
like radiation?
Would you need to see the actual images to make that opinion?
And if so, should I get the images to you?
Thank you.
So this is a person who showed metastasis to the bone.
And so the real question is, when would I recommend radiation or at least looking into doing
radiation when you have metastasis to bone?
And the answer would be, when you have one or two or three sites where there's a lot
of damage where there could be pathological fracture, or you have a lot of pain that
is coming from that site.
If you have a speckled, which is a radiographic term, if you have a speckled distribution of
lytic lesions, which radiographically they would say that there's just a broad band speckled
distribution of lesions throughout the spine or something like that that makes some kind
of comment like that.
No radiation really isn't in the order.
So radiation is something you would do if you had destruction of the L5 vertebrae, the fifth
lumbar vertebrae or where there's it's concentrated and there's in one or two spots and it's a weight
buried bone and or it is causing the person a lot of pain.
So radiation can be beneficial there.
When it's throughout the whole spine and the person doesn't have specific pain in any areas
of the spine, maybe they just have generalized fatigue or aching or something like that in the
spine, then radiation probably would not even be offered by the radiologist.
So that's, I think that helps answer the question, if that doesn't just feel free to ask more